so you have the heart framework to think
about categories and metrics now which
metrics should you actually track to
make data informed decisions well that
will depend on your product you want to
create a small set of metrics or key
performance indicators that everyone on
your team cares about to do that here's
a process that can help you first you
should think about the top-level goals
for the product or feature this is a
good time to check in with stakeholders
investors and anyone else on the team
the discussion allows you to collect
different ideas for the goals and build
consensus about which goals are most
important now a common mistake is to
define the goals in terms of the metric
for example you might say that your goal
is to increase the number of people who
make a purchase which is common for many
e-commerce websites instead you should
think about the user experience
improvements that could help drive that
change so be sure to narrow in on your
definition of the goal next you want to
pair low level signals to each of the
goals for example at Udacity an
engagement signal might be how many
minutes of video our user watches with
each session you might also look at
failure signals such as failed searches
when a user searches for something but
doesn't click on any results once you
have a couple signals down you should
ask some additional questions to
determine which signals might be best
first you should ask how easy or
difficult is it to track the signal you
might be able to come up with a better
proxy or a different signal to track
that same thing it may be that the
website or app is not instrumented to
log relevant events and actions so you
might need to do some additional
research at this point another question
you should ask is is the signal
sensitive to changes in the design of
the website or the app after you've
thought about your goals and your
signals it's time to craft your specific
metrics the metrics you choose should be
prioritized based on the main goals of
the product that you define first you
can always come back to refine the
metrics based on what you need to do or
from what you learned you also want to
be careful about adding too many metrics
oftentimes your metrics will be
associated with one another and you want
the ones to tell you about user behavior
and about your product you want the
metrics that inform you of what to do
next
download the template in the
downloadables and write your own goals
signals and metrics for some of the
categories in the heart framework you
don't need to have a goal for every
category just think about two or three
goals that you think are most important
to measure for your product once you've
done this activity check this box to
continue